good morning how are you I'm a really
thought I'm a stranger in ultra
technology conference k 10 years over I
attend this conference it is all the
angular momentum strange and because my
phone speaking pardon me okay my name is
Stu moon physics professor emeritus and
also in now i'm a senior research in
christine korea i have introduced
mathematical in my office class in
university I used the mathematica a in
physics physical physical behavior I
will talk about Victoria Alfred phone
[Music]
projection mode trend Lola's John
certain mathematical so SLO polarization
termina in the nature in our society
flow region is very important and
cardinal code in the information society
and science and technology as you know
radio optical communication Kentucky
distribution gravitational observation
killer photons handiness of the
elementary particle terrorist generation
many many medic catalog in the science
and technology use the polarization
in the right in the rat in our nature
[Music]
electromagnetism babe if the electron
working babe this world cannot
communicate and intelligent society
polarization is initially in optics in
flores on a length less progress no I
see I cannot see progression the light
is all light is upon arise without
Polaroids will commit do not
communication so it is very important in
our class in obesity in correlation
phenomena I focus in in physical base
offical other than application or
technology you will consider my kitchen
basically the electromagnetic wave as
you know next education prone an inner
space in a medium in South Africa
mathematical equation is education the
solution solution is equation 6 as you
know electric field is a vector complex
vector complex field even component each
component and composite amplitude this
amplitude according to the polarization
mode so grab all right linear polarized
elliptical solid ice although all wave
equation is oscillation this is the
oscillation tone it is amplitude ton so
[Music]
this'll be a look electric field
described as Jones vector in component I
will use the Joel's vector in presenting
polarization in the main mathematical
system I will show some program and
mathematical in the mathematical using
Jones matrix we can convert Jones vector
by this
education 10s as a the January DNA for
arise vector such as so right-handed
circularly polarized this elliptically
polarized this and linear polarizer 40
today's dinner acha trip halfway a field
that we might we convert the
polarization mode in a realistic however
flourish cotoneaster duality rebou rebou
and also particle the we must treat
polarization as quantum electrodynamics
you know as I gonville is plus minus
Harbor one if we let harmoni code one
then polarization hell it is plus minus
one you can specify this program we
confirm the hollister of the
polarization now the helicity of the
polarization is the key word in the
modern physics and cosmology and quantum
communication as you know there we can
compound polarization mode
this is this is no no way no way this is
this is circular polarizer this is
linear polarizer this is last two
electrical polarizer we can see the
direct polarization mode into after
calculation obom in Mathematica
we showed a program i named aj DP
empathy dynamic culture a platform
manipulating polarization po of HO train
platform this is a low in your eye oh oh
oh so mega
[Music]
I'm sony I'm sorry
are properly not focus so i am sorry and
just keep skin and this file you can
load the this program in my sight I'm
sorry yeah whether it's a computation
you will find you this article is a
publish publish Jacob fiesta I will tell
you in my in my home the side thank you
[Applause]